see is when the highest degree term in
the numerator is higher than the highest
degree term in the denominator okay or
if the degree in the numerator and the
denominator are the same then that's
considered an improper fraction so what
you really want is you want the degree
in the numerator the highest degree to
be lower than the degree in the
denominator so if you do get a scenario
like this it's considered improper and
you want to do long division so I'm
going to show you how to do that right
now we're going to take x squared plus
3x plus 2 goes into X cubed plus 3x
squared plus 6x plus 7
okay so x squared goes into X cubed x
times so that's we're left with x cubed
plus 3x squared plus 2x you want to
subtract so that's going to give you 4x
plus 7
now this degree here is lower than this
degree
that's the remainder we put the
remainder over the divisor so what we
have is we have an X plus 4x plus 7 all
divided by x squared plus 3x plus 2 now
what you want to do is you want to do
the partial fraction decomposition on
this fraction here so you can see the
denominator can be factored okay so this
can be factored as X plus 2 X plus 1
okay so what we're going to do is we're
going to break this down and so what
we've got it will start over here we've
got 4x plus 7 over X plus 2 times X plus
1 equals now these are linear factors
linear means that see how they're just
to the first degree okay and they're not
repeated you don't see like X plus 2
squared or X plus 1 cubed there's just
one of them okay so what we do is we
break this down into a over X plus 2
plus B over X plus 1 and what we're
trying to do now is solve for these
numerators a and B ok and notice that a
is a constant B is a constant and it's
one degree lower okay then these linear
factors that
- the first okay so all we're gonna do
now is we're going to clear the
denominators so it's gonna make it a
little bit easier to solve and we're
gonna multiply the left and right sides
of this equation by X plus 2 X plus 1
that's the common denominator so if we
do that we're multiplying this by X plus
2 X plus 1 that cancels the denominator
when we multiply this by X plus 2 X plus
1 X plus 2's are going to cancel and
you're just going to be left with a
times X plus 1 and when you multiply
this fraction by X plus 2 X plus 1
you're just going to be left with B
times X plus 2
ok so we've cleared the denominators now
we want to solve for a and B so let's be
strategic here let's set X equal to
negative 1 that will make this term 0
which will cancel all that out and we
will be able to solve for B so let's let
X equal negative 1 so if we do that we
get negative 4 plus 7 which is 3 this
cancels out we get negative 1 plus 2 is
1 times B is B so now we know that B
equals 3 if we let X equal negative 2
that's going to make this zero that'll
cancel out this term and we have
negative 2 plus 1 is negative 1 times a
so negative a equals negative 2 times 4
is negative 8 plus 7 is negative 1 so
you can see a equals 1 what you want to
do now for the last step is put these
back in okay because it other students
may have switched these they might have
put B here and a here so what your
teacher is looking for are those
original fractions okay and so that's
going to be 1 over X plus 2 plus 3 over
X plus 1 plus the acts that we had
originally when we did the long division
okay so that's plus X so the idea here
is is that if you were given these three
quantities and you've got common
denominators for all of them you
combined them together into one fraction
this is the fraction that you would have
ended up with right here all we did is
we reverse that process broke it down to
the original fractions and that's why
they call it partial fraction
decomposition so this is how you work
with the improper fractions when you're
doing
correction decomposition check out some
of the other videos about partial
fractions and I'll see you in the next
video